um how do you learn to not care about
what other people think of you
this is a hard one and this is what i'm
screwing up right now
the way to forget the insults is to not
take in the compliments in the first
place
because when someone insults you
for that insult to affect you
it has to hit in self-image that you
have created and that self-image was
created through compliments
and through as a kind of a defense
mechanism so
if you can avoid
getting happy
this is obviously hard but if you can
get avoid being happy when somebody
compliments you then you won't be as
insulted when they insult you also for
an insult to really affect you it has to
have some level of truth to it um if
you're real thin and i call you fat or
if you're old and i call you and you're
you're young i call you old it's not
gonna stick
um
so
there has to be some small level of
truth in it for it to affect you
so you have to think deep down like what
did this person say that was true that i
don't want to hear
especially if an insult like really
sticks with you for a while now
obviously someone's slandering you
that's different you know your
reputation can be destroyed and so on
but
uh i just mean sort of like if someone
for example says that you're um you know
an angry person or an arrogant person
you get all worked up over it there's
probably some level of truth to it
because if we're talking and i'm looking
here
i don't know what you're going to do
next and i'm going to put disjunctions
into the like they're like
bad chords in the melody of our of our
conversation and the reason is i'm not
paying attention
so that's why the eye is the thing at
the top of the pyramid it's like the
thing that enables you to win the set of
all possible dominance harkies is the
eye pay attention pay attention that's
the critical issue that's why the
egyptians worshipped horus that's why
horus was the thing that rescued osiris
from the from the depths it's the
capacity to pay attention what do you
pay attention to most
what your right hemisphere signals as
anomalous it attracts your attention
it's like this isn't going quite right
i'm not looking at that
wrong
that's what you look at that's what you
look at what's not going right because
that's see that's the terrible monster
that might eat you but it's also the
place you get all the information
so
that's why it's useful to have
discussions with your enemies
because they will tell you things you do
not know and that's such a great thing
because if you don't know them well
you're not very smart are you you know
there may be a time when you go
somewhere that's the thing you need to
know
and maybe your enemy will tell you why
you're such a fool you know and a bunch
of other things that aren't true too
but even one thing that's accurate it's
like yeah thanks very much man maybe
i'll do some work on that and i won't
have to carry that forward
so and then that's part of the reason
again why the terrible predator it's
always the terrible predator that has
the gold it's like it's the person who
delivers the message you do not want to
hear
so it's rough it's rough but it doesn't
matter
life is rough
elsewhere i've written about this and
that is when somebody insults you
what's the best way to respond standard
way to respond is what to get insulted
to insult them back and to get angry
that they've insulted you
much better way laugh it off
because then it does you no harm at all
and you know what it's one of the worst
ways from their point of view they
insulted you and you just giggled right
so that in itself is a much worse uh
kind of insult than if you had a because
they expect you to say something
negative back
or another similar thing if somebody
insults you you just carry on as if they
hadn't said anything at all
and then you watch and what they'll do
is they'll they'll repeat the insult
thinking
you know maybe he didn't hear me and
then you'll say oh no i heard you and
then you just carry on talking uh so
it's a very interesting response you
frame it as a joke
and then what happens you don't trigger
the negative emotions
so other frames that you can use
when somebody does something
that harms you in some way
you can allow yourself to get angry and
then you're going to have to deal with
that anger and that anger is going to
cost you
or you can frame it as a simple
incompetence on the person isn't that
unfortunate that person is incompetent
maybe he wasn't educated properly maybe
he had a hard childhood but he's simply
incompetent i'm not going to assume
that he he messed up the way he did in
order to ruin my day i'm going to assume
that it's just a poor incompetent person
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so